there's plenty of muscle in laughs in
the upcoming Jumanji sequel and only ET
can take you behind the scenes this time
around Danny DeVito turns into me Danny
Glover turns into Kevin Hart did I die
and turn into some kind of a small
muscular boy scout
aquafina comes on and she creates this
awesome new character you know I thought
I was doing a rom-com she's got moves
sass and style it's really unlimited
with who can come in and become these
avatars well that you don't see every
day behind the scenes there was a little
bit of Jack Black dancing in the snow
Nick was getting dramatic and then
playing dead and of course play fighting
between the rock and Kevin Hart
she knows pop you can't make a good
movie without great relationships we
have one filming took two months there's
definitely lots of high wire action and
even a revolving suspension bridge but
the biggest work hazard was the cast
doing many of their own stunts well
trying at least cannot wait to see this
movie and by the way we will catch up
with Kevin and the entire Jumanji crew
later this week
[Music]